principles for success an ultra
mini-series adventure in 30 minutes and
in eight episodes episode for the abyss
we progress forward until we encounter
setbacks whether or not we get out of
them and continue forward or spiral
downward depends on whether or not we're
willing to face the failure objectively
and make the right decisions to turn the
loop upward again something terrible
happened to me in 1982 when I bet
everything on a depression that never
came
the period between 1979 and 1982 was one
of extreme turbulence for the global
economy and markets and for me and I
believe that the US economy with the
world economy tied to it was headed
toward a catastrophe this view was
extremely controversial
I wanted the great upside and very
publicly took a big risk and was wrong
dead wall after a delay the stock market
began a big bull market that lasted 18
years and the US economy enjoyed the
greatest growth period in its history
this experience was like a blow to my
head with a baseball bat I had to cut my
losses so that my company Bridgewater
was left with one employee me I was so
broke I had to borrow $4,000 from my dad
to pay my bills but even worse was
having to let go the people I cared so
much about I wondered whether I should
give up my dream of working for myself
and play it safe by working for someone
else in a job that would require me to
put on a tie and commute every day
though I knew that for me taking less
risk would mean having a less great life
being so wrong and especially being so
publicly wrong was painfully humbling I
am still shocked and embarrassed by how
arrogant I was in being totally
confident in a totally incorrect view
though I'd been right much more than I'd
been wrong I had let one bad bet erase
all my good ones I thought very hard
about the relationship between risk and
reward
and how to manage them but I couldn't
see a path forward that would give me
the rewards I wanted without
unacceptable risk this kind of
experience happens to everyone it will
happen to you you will lose something or
someone you think you can't live without
or you will suffer a terrible illness or
injury or your career will fall apart
before your eyes you might think that
your life is ruined and that there is no
way to go forward but it will pass I
assure you that there is always a best
path forward and you probably just don't
see it yet you just have to reflect well
to find it you have to embrace your
reality in Episode five I'll show you
how this realization drove me to wonder
how reality works and how to best deal
with it
[Music]